[Music]
oh
good morning gamers oh god i forgot i
forgot i forgot
come back oh god it's getting dark oh no
is he lost forever
no no this is not happening
oh come back
i built you a house where is he
he is there it is oh
i don't care if i die gotta make it back
before it gets dark
where'd he go there he is don't cross
the border
don't cross the border don't cross the
border don't carry supporters crush the
product
stop oh it's dark let's just go back in
let's just go back in bruh i get it i
get it
but no don't ever do that
oh it gets dark so quick hurry up
i told you how many times have you tried
to escape
i don't get it stop it
all right get in here he finds that one
block that is missing and he just
yeets out of it alright here we go no
no is there any holes is there any holes
there's no holes there's no holes
you could call that wholesome look at
this dude
why would you want to go anywhere else
this is beautiful i'll make it even
better it's going to be a ton of flowers
yeah don't lean
all right seriously okay i'm going to
bed
crisis adverted we're fine gamers
hardcore sears continues i need better
gear
i'm not nearly strong enough i take so
much damage i think i have a treasure
map
it's digging no
stop that
he drowned
no it was a swimming pool you idiot
it's a kid bull oh
he was my father ah
oh that hurts that just [ __ ] hurts
[Music]
who drowns in the kid pool it look it's
a half slab
how is this part how is this possible
how is this possible i don't
i can't believe it my best friend he's
been there since
[Music]
oh this is so sad
i have no one now i have absolutely no
one
oh side cue the funeral music
i don't know how to spell his name but
he was a hero
a father a son
rest in peace dude i will play this song
in your honor
he loved this song
[Music]
oh my gosh
rest in peace you will be missed
[Music]
what's the point what's the point of a
anything what's the point of anything
why
why why uh
it's i'm just sad i'm just sad now
all right we're gonna have to do
something to cheer me up i could really
use a
treasure a treasure hunt
blood treasure hunts he really he he
loved it
no that's not how you water plants
oh i'm the only farmer in the world that
set themselves up oh
gosh i'm a minecraft veteran okay
anything i do is intentional and it has
a purpose that you probably don't
understand
because you're not a very don't
criticize what you can't understand
like my love for all right couch a dear
friend of mine just died
so you get the frick yeah i'll kill the
moms in front of the children
as a token of my gratitude what up
jurgen
you wouldn't die would you okay so this
man
is actually on land so it should be this
direction
okay this could be a little adventure
i know would appreciate this is correct
this is south this is really far away
maybe i need a boat
damn i'm blowing away how good minecraft
looks with ray tracing
it's so worth it and it runs better i
don't get it i'm just checking the
compass so i gotta go this way
[Music]
oh not a bunny it's dead
now everyone have to suffer like did
why did i i don't get it i thought would
be
he stayed in my house i didn't do
anything
he should have lived all right let's
find this treasure
what is that is that a well yeah it's
here and now we go
this way is anything spawning wells
or this is just it that's so cool cool
it's getting dark guys that's fine
sorry chicken oh my god yes
i could make a bed
i need to sleep bro i'm sleeping
stop it oh god i'm dead
this is the saddest sleep night of all
time
welcome back we're having an awful time
it's been a day it's just been an
episode for you
where am i i dug this hole
i'm free oh you're still here fantastic
i don't have a shield just die
you can't shoot me i'm a fish always
fall for it
idiots all right we were treasure
hunting
it was going great which way are we
going excuse me pig
you know the treasure oh he offered his
meat as treasure
that's so sweet what do i need ah
stop you're supposed to be dead they're
defying laws of physics do i actually
not have a shield because then i
actually need to make one
remember what you owe you own the debt
am i gonna i'm gonna die i'm gonna die
there's no way i'm gonna make i have a
shield never mind we're fine
a lot of people don't notice furnace if
you have two you can make a third one
all right cooking up i didn't think this
was a requirement but i think i need to
set up like a mini base cause
i'm gonna die i can't survive in the
wild on my own apparently
i need an adult supervision a lot of
people don't notice you can have three
furnaces
in your extra house i'm
actually upset why am i so mad oh
there's a fortress thing
have i not discovered that i feel like
i've seen that before all right
the treasure hunt continues i got my
little mini base
oh wow it looks so good thank you felix
it's gone i've resorted to talking to
myself this is great
all right so i'm facing north i need to
go south right
yeah yeah yeah if i'm looking south
i need to head to the right which is
west
oh my my brain is too large we're gonna
find the treasure bros
or sorry 19 year olds sorry oh look you
found
we found the treasure it's a dead pig
okay okay we're getting close
nice i'm dying
have you guys seen treasure oh okay
you're dead
getting closer oh is that the tippy
toppy is that the tippy toppy i gotcha
it's right here oh my gosh it's right at
the tippy toppy
all right we better start digging here
i need loot i'm poor
oh found it easy oh my
god oh i'm not pouring anymore screw
poor people
i got nothing in common with you
yeah oh my god it looks so good
look at this amazing
don't come near me he was going to seal
my diamonds i know it
this is such a donkey you want to come
with me i don't have
i don't have anything for you this is
such a nice lovely area
full of wildlife and animal not anymore
someone has to pay for what happened
i just spat all over god damn all right
it's night time no problem because i got
secret base
nice clean now that it's morning again
we're going to strike we're going to
infiltrate it's happening now
good morning good night
oh there's actually a lot of
oh my god how is it so many stop
they're all shooting each other is this
dangerous i can't tell
they're all just shooting each other oh
my god how is it so many
[Music]
all right my house thank you
wow wow wow
wow what a what a load
thanks guys wow incredible that was
totally worth
well done fellas is there any way i can
cheese them
what am i looking at here this is nuts
stop stop
they keep spawning i'm out i'm out ariel
adios amigos
watch out for the hole there's so many
this is my house this is where i live
you guys can't come
leave oh my
you guys are amazing warriors i give you
that
they're so stupid
boom
oh god
i'll take the xp oh yeah all right we're
heading back home
back home back home
i sort of get it now everyone else
in this world is technically playing on
hardcore and now i
am as well so profound so deep
look the dolphins there she is
bloody beautiful in it brick time
what the hell you don't want to freak
what's wrong with you it's always time
to prick come on
come on idiots dumbasses
i feel like i built the right side a
little too big but whatever
here i brought back some some chicken
he loved chicken
[Music]
i can't even look at it just makes me
sad
hey look it's little white bunny
[Music]
so famous famous bunny yeah i remember i
heard lava here
that's a bit strange isn't it be good to
have quick access to obsidian honestly
i actually need the chicken guys don't
judge me there you are
see i knew i'd find you
oh you snake you actual garbage human
trash
your bottom of the food chain you're
nothing and no one
[ __ ] a lot of people don't know
furnace
let's kill the lava
[Music]
actually murdered okay we got some
obsidian
nice i kind of just want to do some
housekeeping you know
clean up this area a bit but the problem
is that's not fun to do
on camera but then if i do everyone's
gonna be me
oh builder he borrowed off camera that
yeah that's more how you sound like
yeah you sound like his couch shut up
what are they even doing
i hate them so much
i don't even have to worry about closing
the door anymore this is so
sad
all right it's ugly as hell but at least
i have a transportation system that's
quicker yeah
that's what i do that's what everyone
wanted felix
what are you doing i i know i'm sorry
i'm sorry the journey to not be poor
continues
that's right we're gonna set up another
portal
who knows maybe this time it won't be
garbage
oh god uh can you get off my bridge bro
oh this is bad you can knock me out
oh there's two
die oh
my bridge all right yeah what have we
got
come on a beehive come on
seriously i'm in the middle i'm in the
middle of the ocean
really this this this is where you
this game sucks well well well what do
we have there
okay i'll take it don't you miss van
at least sven wouldn't die like stinky
[Music]
this is how our forefathers used to
travel
across the oceans amazing oh dude
there's one there and one there what
oh yeah it's gamer time no more pour i
had enough
it's not super rare like right next to
each other what
what i do like what halo wife bunny
oh you're lucky come on give me
something good baby
okay you're again
sure project that protection or okay
that's pretty good right
uh huh
there it is feather falling whoa two
saddles
yeah that's a win so is it possible to
mine this
oh god this is like a bad idea hold up
because there's diamonds underneath
right
oh my god it works yeah
baby that's my
diamond i'm rich now
yeah bye i knew it i know you could do
that
so whatever i'm too rich i don't know
what to throw away
hey look guys it's dark of course stupid
the white bunny's fault
all right let's get the other one i want
mega loot
i'm swedish i just come for your pants
[Music]
no pants yeah okay no i haven't been
here
all right all we got to do is not blow
up and the reward
is great oh god
don't ever do that don't ever do that
what is happening here
oh okay what do we get respiration i
don't know what that does i'm sure it's
super epic because i'm so rich
oh i'm too rich oh god
oh my gosh dude too much money and power
i get it now stealing stuff is super
good
all right all right i'm out seeing my
trial seas are there people on my bridge
am i wearing gold oh oh that's bad
uh but i'm so rich can i wear the horse
armor
can i make it
[Music]
don't shoot i am sweet
get off my bridge bro get off my bridge
get off my bridge
idiot you're again
my man my baby my boo
look what i got you man oh yeah you look
good man you look good
yeah keep it up you look sexy that's
that's weird to call horus sexy but
it's the only word i'm glad i still want
this way when i
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
oh genius i'm a genius thank you thank
you thank you
look how rich i am oh i'm so rich yeah
i'm it's hap it's happening we're gonna
make a
ton of tnt right oh dude i can make so
many
whoa it's done there doesn't that mean
something yo
hello hey me getting some sand turned
into hey i need to clean up the sand
make it look good you know
all right let's make more tnt bing
bamboo
bait whoa i want to blow all this up
because i want that to be the only hill
right uh it seems like a bad idea and it
probably is but i'm doing it so it
doesn't matter
hopefully the cows don't blow up you
know who am i kidding i really don't
care
okay let's try i don't i don't know how
to
do this efficiently i'm just i'm just
doing it
okay i think that will blow up okay
let's do
this
did it not work what happened oh i
forgot you need an
all right i forgot new new plane
run
that was it that was it pathetic dude
again
bro i need to i need to blow up this
entire mountain let's just do it the
old-fashioned way
oh did the cows take damage pansies
whoa i actually took that one the cows
are afraid
which makes this even better it's just
thunder you proceeds come on
oh you can lift them in there i don't
know that i mean i knew that
stop dying geez some of them actually
died
what a bunch of losers what a bunch of
idiots all right this will be a little
[Music]
scary
stop dying jeez all right let's allow my
last one
bro i'm sorry i'm look i made it bigger
i made it i made it bigger for you
you're welcome oh
oh geez he's fine that's a lot of damage
nice i'm gonna keep cleaning that up
was there always a hole in the ceiling
you telling me could have escaped this
whole time but it didn't because he
loves me
i just keep charting
it hurts too much my heart breaking
stone
this weather is perfectly fitting for
this episode
there again let's go let's ride baby
this looks so sad everything is just sad
it's like a thousand-year curse because
it's gone what is this cake by the way
what the hell
at least i have you with me again
at least you're with me
oh look at that after rain comes
sunshine
gamers smash like for respect
for my man
see you in the next episode we're
officially beating this game
and honor his legacy must live on
y'all can stop escaping